I have always been fascinated with
Vietnam and felt that it was a seminal
event in our nation's history and you
know welcome the idea to do a film about
the last days of Vietnam but I felt that
Vietnam has been so covered by
documentaries and books and I didn't
know if I could add anything new to the
equation and you know what I think a lot
of us are familiar with the iconic image
of the helicopter coming off of what we
think is the embassy it's not in fact
the Embassy as we all now know that was
really what I know right and there was
so much I didn't know and once I
uncovered the events and how dramatic
they were and how extraordinary they
were I was kind of blown away about how
much I didn't know and then when you
know we started uncovering these
extraordinary stories of Stuart
Harrington and the USS Kirk and people
Americans and Vietnamese who went
against US policy to sacrifice
themselves and to save the lives of the
Vietnamese and I was really hooked and I
think I also was excited about this film
because of the timeliness at that point
we were on the brink of getting out of
Iraq and Afghanistan and I felt even
though these were events that took place
40 years ago they have a lot of
resonance today you know there are
images coming out of Iraq where families
are desperately trying to get on
American helicopters and it feels like
Saigon 40 years ago the story itself is
just in its DNA is this amazingly
dramatic story it has this structure
that is it's almost you know like a
disaster film where the tsunamis coming
or them you know the bad guys were
coming and there's a ticking clock and
everybody has to try and get out and and
so you know we had that to start with
and we wrote up a treatment and it was a
very brief document because it came
across really quickly how you know
engaging and compelling and terrifying a
story it would be well I must say I was
quite astounded after we opened this
marvelous film that this marvelous lady
made at the Sundance Film Festival and
the audience was sizable audience young
and old and they came to me and they
said almost to the voice we never know
we never knew and it dawned on me that
half the people in the audience weren't
born at the time and the other half had
focused on Watergate the yom kippur war
the quadrupling of a barrel of crude and
the price and the impact on the economy
and that even though this was something
that I lived and breathed for the better
part of four years of my life it seemed
so much different to most people and one
of the things that I really will always
be grateful to Rory is that she did a
film about those events which instead of
being the was me weeping and gnashing of
teeth of a horrible we are as a country
focused on that side that dimension of
the story that normally doesn't get any
attention we really tried to contain
this story to this moment in time and as
much as we could take the politics out
of it and you know as Mark said there's
no experts there's no narrator there's
nobody looking back giving opinions
about this moment it's all the
first-hand accounts of what happened you
know there's nothing that you know that
the film tells you that the people in
the film don't know so you're learning
it as they learn it and so you know our
hope was that the experience would be as
though you were there one of my
experiences after Vietnam and other wars
that I had the misfortune or fortune to
be in was that I would always finally
get out from wherever it was whether it
was Desert Storm or the invasion of
Panama or Vietnam and then I'd see the
coverage of it in the documentaries and
I'd always ask myself you know if that
was Vietnam where was I that said in
this particular one it brings it home to
me with such a vivid real
ilysm that even 40 years later it
catches me emotionally by leaving the
commentary in the description of events
up to the people who were there you get
something that you rarely find these
days and that is its historicity its
veracity its absolute verra similis
verisimilitude do you have any hopes do
you think there may be any way that this
could help to change people's
perceptions about if not the overall
legacy then some of the human impact and
the human performances of the time I
think so although Vietnam has always
been such a contentious issue and I
certainly agree with Rory and mark that
to skirt around the politics of it was
the only way to a the only way to go
here there are still die hard camps of
people out there who made up their minds
about Vietnam 20 30 40 years ago and
they'll probably never change their
minds I think in line with what you're
saying politically you know I it sort of
it when we finish this film I looked at
it and I thought gosh Nixon comes across
pretty well in this film and Kissinger's
pretty good and maybe we shouldn't have
gotten out of Vietnam and you know kind
of all these ideas that are very counter
to my kind of lefty perspective on
things in the end when our policy
collapses and out on the ground are all
these people who because policy
decisions were made were deployed out
there and you can put in here Vietnam or
you can put Iraq or Afghanistan people
are out there to implement these
policies and if the policy is ill
thought out if as in the case of Vietnam
you grossly underestimate the North
Vietnamese and overestimate the South
Vietnamese what you get is what you saw
on the screen here and these human
events can really claw at your heart so
to know and to experience war firsthand
or the consequences of a failed war is
to as a person get this sense that these
policy decisions beget these human
events
and this is how it translates on the
ground one of the lessons that I think
I've learned in making this film is that
by april of nineteen seventy five there
were very few good options available and
you know had the head congress passed
722 million i think it would have made a
difference i don't think it would have
changed the tide of what happened so i
think the lesson to me is that once you
start a war you can lose control over it
and then you can get into a situation
like this quite easily and so when we're
thinking about these engagements with
Isis and going back into Iraq and Syria
I think it's really important imperative
that our leaders answer the questions
that what is our exit strategy what is
our plan what is our responsibility to
the people on the ground thank